[Musik]
was ist passiert
auch bei citys welt in der küche geht
mal was schönes spiel
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
halte gibt es endlich mal wieder ein
nachgemacht video und viele von euch
haben schon gefragt ob ich nicht mal
oreo kekse nachmachen kann also wer oreo
kekse nicht kennt das sind schokolade
vanille kekse die vegan sind und die
schmecken sehr schokoladig wandel ich
liebe sie aber manche mögen sie nicht
aber davon kenne ich nur ganz wenige
jedenfalls werde ich heute oreo kekse
nachmachen und die sind wirklich von
natur aus schon vegan an zutaten haben
die nämlich drin mehl zucker palmöl und
rapsöl kakaopulver ein bisschen back
trieb mittel und nochmal glukose ja ich
frage mich wo da als man ende ist sie
schmecken aber nötig naja egal kann
milch enthalten kann milch enthalten
wahrscheinlich wird er in der
keksproduktion noch ein keks eingestellt
der milch enthält daher aber so von den
zutaten her sind sie wirklich vegan
die werde ich mir zu bereiten statt
palmöl auf palmöl verzichte ich da
palmöl wirklich ein sehr minderwertiges
öl ist und da wirklich auch die welt
leider dafür abgeholzt werden
hallo mama ich verwende stattdessen
kokosöl und da gibt es auch wirklich ein
missverständnis also kokosöl und palmöl
sind ganz verschiedene dinge für den
mürbeteig verwende ich 100 gramm zucker
100 gramm cacau eine prise salz 200
gramm 200 gramm kokosöl etwas meinl
extrakt und schwarze lebensmittel
verpasste beim eine nachmacht
nachgemacht sachen
es klingt so als wüsste ich nicht wie
sonst nichts schmeckt aber was wird das
team der werbung das aufgedreht haben
sehr knusprig und schokoladig also ich
weiß nicht wie sie hier das kakaopulver
oder die farbe so schwarz bekommen
entweder fernsehen benutzen vielleicht
etwas die heißt schwarz weiß ich mein
ich komme gleich drauf egal jedenfalls
machen wir jetzt ich komme gleich drauf
was ich sagen wollte
jedenfalls machen wir zuerst mal den
teig das ist jetzt ein ganz normaler
mürbeteig ihr könnt natürlich auch
butter verwenden stabs kokosöl dann sind
sie aber nicht mehr vegan und ich mache
es jetzt vegan
man kann nämlich damals kamen auch mit
essen muss nämlich einfach alle
trockenen zutaten wie salz kakaopulver
und beim kakaopulver bitte aufpassen
kein nesquik oder kleinen körper
benutzen sondern wirklich cacau ungelöst
und etwas zucker gebe ich hier gleich
man den extrakten einfach alle zutaten
hinzu auch das kokosöl und weil kokosöl
bei mir bei raumtemperatur gelagert wird
und die küche gerade sehr warm ist ist
es flüssig aber wenn es etwas kühler ist
dann ist es fest ich probiere das jetzt
ich hab so jetzt auch noch nie in
leipzig nur mit kokosöl gemacht aber das
war jetzt einfach aus ist einfach ein 12
3 mio
und ich denke schon
ganz geklappt und ich nehme ich probiere
es erstmal so und cook als auch wirklich
noch farbe zufügt und jetzt einfach
alles verkneten
ok ich merke jetzt 1 1 1 2 3 mehrheit
mit kokosöl geht nicht denn gutes daran
dass das kokosöl natürlich bei ist aber
ich gebe jetzt einfach 50 gramm mehr
mehr dazu oder ich mach es wie im
original und gebt noch stärker dazu denn
da ist auch bei zum stärke darin meine
schwester ist zwar meist stärker aber
ich mache das jetzt 50 gramm stärke noch
dazu also wenn ich mir das so anschaue
und den keks ein vergleich
sieht schon gut aus von der farbe haben
jetzt noch fahrbereit
gleich zum tropfen ein tropfen muss man
ab
[Musik]
ich gehe jetzt erstmal ein kühlschrank
damit nämlich dass kokosfett jetzt
wieder fest werden kann
abgedeckt natürlich so etwa eine halbe
stunde
und dann gucke ich auch dass ich gleich
aus holen lässt die butter werde es
jetzt ein bisschen einfacher also bei
butter bleibt da wirklich sein altes
rezept beim 1 2 3 3 aber kokosfett es
einfach weiter und hatten gegen den
geringeren schmelzpunkt als butter
deswegen schmilzt kokosfett einfach
schneller
deswegen musste ich dann zum
experimentieren schon wieder ein
schmeckst als glatten teig probiert der
schmeckt so jetzt doch noch zu bitter
wegen dem kakaopulver das heißt ich muss
mehr zucker dazugeben oreo kekse sind
halt auch sehr süß ich probier's mal mit
80 gramm und dann mache ich gleich noch
eine variante mit butter das heißt eine
nicht veganer variante da weiß ich
nämlich auch die butter wird fest und
der betrag wird schön kalt aber ihr seht
auch hier schon der 15 minuten im
kühlschrank wird schon fest
also da könnte auch gerne kühlschrank
kaltes kokosfett verwenden und dann
klappt das auch super einmal probieren
ich möchte mich mag das bittere der
schokolade aber nicht jeder mag
wie gesagt der kommt kurz in den
kühlschrank dann zeige ich euch kurz
hier die anderen zutaten für den teig
nämlich 200 gramm puderzucker 100 gramm
cacau eine prise salz 250 g mehl 250
kalte butter 2 eigelbe und etwas mangel
extrakt ihr könnt jetzt diesen weg
entweder auch mit den händen verkneten
oder mit dem handrührgerät ich nehme für
mich meist entweder hier oben den mix
also den multi zerkleinerer oder
tatsächlich den flach hörer von der
küchenmaschine es geht einfach am
schnellsten mir beteiligt hat man früher
auch hektik genannt und der wird auch
tatsächlich mit dem messer zerhackt ich
habe auch so eine sache mit dem geht es
auch gut also den könnte echt auf
unterschiedliche art und weise
herstellen und jetzt einfach alle
zutaten auf einmal miteinander
vermischen
ein extrakt wäre dann auch mal das so
ist doch traurig sein aber es ist noch
wann ein extrakt drin für mindestens
zwei weil man kann sehr einfach mit
etwas milch ausspülen
da half auch ganz gut denn ich hatte
gerade ein gelbe übrig im kühlschrank
kurz ein bisschen mixen und dann das
restliche mehl dazugeben
[Musik]
einfach kurz mit den händen zusammen
kneten und habe ich jetzt puderzucker
verwendet weil puderzucker einfach schon
sehr fein ist und kristallzucker sich
wirklich im teig noch gut auflösen muss
und so muss man ihnen jetzt nicht allzu
lange kühlen da muss jetzt einfach nur
noch schön kalt werden und könnte immer
auch schon über nacht schon herstellung
im kühlschrank lagern oder auch auf
frauen einfrieren und ich halbiert den
jetzt kurz so kohls nämlich noch
schneller ab und ich drücke immer gerne
einfach flach in einen teller statt eine
kugel zu formen
text ab und dann kommt wirklich für eine
halbe stunde bis stunden in den
kühlschrank
[Musik]
unser ots fahrer heute wie sein name
ich hab dich neulich schon als ich sehe
dich ja oft und da habe ich schon sah
unser lieblings apps war greifbar
aber dann hat an daneben nebeneingang
geklingelt ich mach dir kaffee kaffee
schwarz mit zuckerguss jetzt jemanden
grüßen schön groß aber erstmal braucht
kommentar ist fertig kann auch die taste
mitnehmen
dies für dich ein geschenk von zucker es
gibt ein buch mit soja packt sie gerne
oder kocht sie gerne seine tochter auch
trägt sie das hier ja nix einfach dahin
nicht spiel gleich wie hessen tochter
olivia mit vg danke für die pakete ja
gerne da fliegt gehalten mit kannst
irgendwann zu hause eine kollektion
machen jedes jahr wieder im café kriegst
bis bald ich nehme jetzt mann aus gold
starb mit ihren abstand bringen und habe
jetzt die 5 mm ringe dran das heißt
meint 15 millimeter dick ausgerollt und
auch schön gleichmäßig wenn ihr sohn aus
dem stab nicht habt dann könnt ihr ganz
einfach teig hölzer nehmen die gibt es
auch im baumarkt zum beispiel hier könnt
ihr einfach zu schneiden einfach so ein
buchenholz sich hinlegen und dann habt
ihr schön diesen abstand und die kekse
backen gleichmäßig durch da ist an
keiner zu durch und noch keine und
keiner zugang
das heißt alles schön gleichmäßig okay
jetzt mache ich erstmal mit dem veganen
teig weiter der ist jetzt schön fest
jetzt einmal kurz durchkneten
echt schwierig denn das kokosfett wird
natürlich sofort reich aber ich wollte
halt echt auf vegane butter verzichten
denn vegane butter hat meistens soja mit
drin und so mag ich nicht so gerne
ok also ich probier's und zur not kühle
ich den teig einfach zwischendurch
unterricht echt extrem gut nach
und jetzt nehme ich runde ausstecher
cook jetzt mal nach der größe da passt
der kleinste aussteller passt und weil
jetzt der kokos teig etwas weich ist
werde ich jetzt den nicht stempeln
das heißt die stecke ich jetzt ganz
einfach rund aus vorher den aussteller
immer in mehl wälzen oder e-mail tauchen
und ein mal ausstechen
ich sehe schon dass schon ein bisschen
schwierig mit kokosöl da macht sich die
industrie hat schon so einfach mit
palmfett und mit rapsöl
aber ich wollte dass gute benutzt
ich lebe jetzt hier drauf und dann ist
aber ganz wichtig dass man sie einfriert
oder zumindest in den kühlschrank gibt
bisher noch mal richtig schön fest
werden richtig kalt in der zwischenzeit
hat sich schon mal den ofen vor und
macht der zirkus fertig und dann geht es
gleich mit dem nächsten tag weiter mit
dem muttertag der ist ein bisschen
einfacher also wenn ihr nicht unbedingt
vegan machen müsst dann macht mit butter
ansonsten kündigt gerne auch veganer
mutter benutzen
aber wie gesagt ich wollte jetzt einfach
das gute kokosöl benutzen
[Musik]
breaking news aus waghäusel wir haben 12
35 und bei sally ging der rauchmelder an
wir sind natürlich live vor ort und
können der besagten sally ein paar
fragen gestellt
sally wie kam es dazu
was ist passiert
es ging im prinzip damit los habe den
ofen auf zehn minuten eingestellt da
sagen die kekse noch perfekter h
aber es war noch nicht durch und ich
hatte damals fünf minuten nachgestellt
und jetzt ist einfach es ist einfach
zerstörte rauen dagegen an und die hexen
verbrannt
ich kann mir sonne erklären wir haben
das wir haben das phänomen gelöst auch
bei citys welt in der küche gibt mal was
schief es lag einfach an der mutter was
lernen wir daraus
ich backe wir damit die richtige bruder
richtige butter nehmen sonst verbrennt
oder die richtige vegane margarine aber
bitte probiert nicht mit kokosfett
kokosfett verbrennt vielen dank für das
interview
wir verlassen den raum sonst leiden wir
eine rauchvergiftung wen wollen sie denn
mein mann murat der bittet die kekse
entsorgen soll
ok murat
tschüss der mürbeteig es jetzt schön
kalt den habe ich jetzt noch mal kurz
durchgeknetet und jetzt ganz normal wie
vorhin auch und hier seht ihr auch schon
an der teig konsistenz der lässt sich
einfach perfekt ausrollen mehrbetrag
ebenso ist wirklich ganz wenig mehr nur
nehmen ausrollen ausstechen und ab aufs
blech und die frist auch dann noch kurz
ein und dann werden sie gebacken und
sich privat backofen stehen und warte ab
wie sie eine schöne bräune haben
die sind jetzt schon gefreut und jetzt
warten sie gewann die mannschafts werden
jetzt wunderschön mama backt jetzt euro
kekse für dich
sie brauchen allerdings noch ich habe
angst auszusprechen brauchen noch drei
minuten
ja
[Musik]
ach schön jetzt sind die kekse gebacken
sie sind perfekt und jetzt mache ich die
creme
hier nehme ich jetzt einfach etwas
weiche butter butter zucker und vanille
extrakt die butter wird jetzt schön
cremig verrührt mit dem puderzucker und
im panel extrakt es dauert auch weg
schon ein paar minuten und bist du schön
weiß cremig ist ich probiere es gleich
auch noch mal mit kokosfett denn ich
finde es einfach ausprobieren
ja aber die mit body werden gut okay die
ist noch nicht ganz reif
ich habe die mutter jetzt einfach in ein
warmes wasserbad erstellt jetzt ist sie
schön weich
so könnt ihr euch auch die wartezeit
bisschen verkürzen
ok jetzt die butter masse weiß cremig es
gebe noch ein bisschen vanille dazu
die letzten tropfen aber es reicht und
das gleiche problem ist aber trotzdem
noch mal in veganer variante mit
kokosfett mal ein anderes kokosfett
genommen was so auf als block im
kühlschrank verkauft wird
ich probier s mal damit vielleicht
denn ein paar megane keks es sind doch
ganz schön geworden
die habe ich einfach länger gekühlt
vielleicht waren sie einfach nur nicht
kühl gelobt die anderen das kann das
sein
okay die pflege ich jetzt ganz kurz zur
seite macht noch die vegane creme das
heißt dafür einfach kokosfett und butter
zucker verrühren und den rest rennella
extrakt
[Musik]
schon krass ist jetzt ein ganz anderes
kokosfett und das hat jetzt eine festere
konsistenz ich glaube wenn ich von
anfang an mit dem gebacken hätte wäre es
einfacher gewesen weil es andere
schmilzt schon bei raumtemperatur um
eine fleißige reporterin sara berührt in
der zwischenzeit schon mal die vegane
variante und ich habe zehn kleine spots
und nehme jetzt wirklich eine kleine
menge setze hier auf einem keks dann
kommt eigentlich nur noch der zweite
obendrauf
und dann habe ich meine mio
[Musik]
okay es war ein langer drehtag du bist
schon da zarate rasende reporterin komm
du auch und dann lassen wir jetzt
probieren okay kommt einfach in die
küche so jetzt bin ich gespannt ich
werde jetzt mal kontrollieren
das ist ein original okay das sieht aus
wie kurras nicht gleich aus das heißt es
hat nicht funktioniert das experiment
ich wusste ganz genau dass das war ein
original loriot ist bringe mal seine
fixe jungs die sind für euch und murat
da steigen
worum es geht
es ist etwas das asbest darin werden
alle sterben alleine zum anfassen ist
trockene erde haben der merapi der ist
es ja gerade gehassten geschmeckt das
geschick das wirst du sagen okay es ist
ganz schwieriger als gedacht weil ganz
original geschmack zu treffen das schon
schwierig
und original es sind ja vegan denn es
wird japan verwendet und halten muss ist
keine werbung ist keiner ich habe das
ganze etwas erklärt drin da durch dieses
mega und die auch im orang utans sind
traurig und dann habe ich es probiert
den vegan
die sind ein bisschen zu lang gebacken
sie treten
die sind vegan haben die
protonenstrahlen apotheker sollten
wissen solange die meisten veganer und
diese zeit mit butter mein gott diese
mit butter umgegangen er helfe mit guter
gemacht weil die schüler seien einfach
und walker der hdw gaarden ist auch egal
denn es ist seit drei tagen begangen
denn es hat alle haare verloren dadurch
konnte sagen
dennis von carius dabei ist veganer von
dem alle haare verloren
wer denn ist da nicht vor drei tagen
noch so aus so so sagt dennis vor drei
tagen noch aus jetzt ist veganer alle
haben das ist schon länger so
aber ja gar nicht mehr über stößt
süßmann stadt nicht süß sind zucker ist
da was kauft einfach eure oreo keksen
gerichtssaal
die sind jetzt nicht schlecht aber ich
finde er ist mein gott ist echt sagen
wollte so gegen voll in die hose war
keine produkt platzieren könnte auch
andere kekse kaufen
die sind genauso tun auch andere mütter
haben tolle kekse
und eur kann uns nicht verklagen da wir
ja das nicht verkauft hieß es nun wissen
was sie da rein gemacht habt keine
ahnung aber geht es dann einfach gut
meldet euch leibniz butterkeks sind die
besten oder die krise und auch von der
beute war der brockeler gruß an große
halle wieder arbeite und emotion
prinzenrolle muss ich das sagen seine
rolle garn nachstehen ist ja das hat
eine dreijährige zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer ma zuschauer geschrieben ganz
ähnlich mühsam chef kloppers auch ganz
ganz lecker ich muss echt sagen bisher
die nach gemacht dass man immer gut aber
das ganze jahr über das bisher fast
autoren ist toll ist am ort heißt auch
teufelszeug sind galaxy leiden unter
www.bw so was für ein krasses video
probiert einfach ein anderes rezept von
mir aus ihr könnt auf die gerne
ausprobieren
ich finde ich hab echt ein bisschen zu
früh kommt der großraum der stadt
gesehen drittel reduzieren sowie fixe
weg probiert gerne aus und es macht ihr
hättet mich ja vorbei der kicker jedoch
die füllung ist heftiger motto sing und
der stadt dicker als theorie oder
senkblei mit soja abgenommen mindestens
drei kilo ohne haare
ich habe die mégane und wichtig ist
denn ist ein spaß gemacht
[Musik]
brocks und gemüse hilft und was wieder
so haare schön look ja früher früher
hatte keine haare gehabt und sei dabei
mit uns gegessen sei dem mann nur obst
und gemüse ist sind seine haare
gewaschen nicht unmut aus dem heimischen
garten
[Musik]